وصل الطفل احمد الى مركز حجر الكل يرى قبل
ايام كحاله مشتبهين فيها
اسهال شديد وارتفاع في درجات الحراره عانى
معهما من الجفاف بعد ان تاكدت اصابته
يحذر الاطباء وعائلته من امكانيه انتشار
المرض بينهم
ويؤكدونا ان احمد واحد من بين الاف
الاطفال شمال غربي سوريا لم يحصلوا على
جرعه لقاح الكليره
استقبلنا خلال الشهر الماضي ما يقارب ال
190 حاله ااه 70% منها كان اطفال و30%
بالغين همم كانت معظم الاصابات اطفال
باعتبارهم اكثر عرضه لحدوث استكشاف
يزداد وتحديد الاصابه بالمرض في مخيمات
النازحين شمالي سوريا خصوصا العشوائيه
منها
وغياب لشبكات الصرف الصحي يشكو النازحون
ندره المياه الصالحه للشرب
ويحاولون وقايه اطفالهم من المرض بتدابير
بسيطه
يشربوا لاولادك
ارسلته منظمه اليونيسيف الدفعه الاولى
تاخر دخول لقاح الكوليرا الى شمال غربي
سوريا ساهم في انتشار المرض خصوصا بين
النازحين وربما يزداد الوضع سوءا مع تاخر
حملات التطعيم التي ستبدا مع نهايه الشهر
القادم بحسب مديريه صحه ادلب
ادام ابو الحسين
مع تركيا